effectivement personne n'aimerait voir
un jour un avion comme celui ci le f 16
américains affronter cet autre machine
russe le sukhoï 27 ici aussi la bataille
se livre à coups de manche à balai et de
remise de gaz mais l'enjeu est
strictement commerciales en impressionne
pour vendre vadim vous présente une
figure acrobatique aux techniques le
cobra que seuls les russes savent et
peuvent réaliser
cela parce que ce biréacteur est
probablement le plus puissant du monde
pourtant les russes n'ont pratiquement
aucune chance de vendre un seul chasseur
ni même un seul hélicoptère de combat
pour la bonne raison que dans la plupart
des pays des budgets militaires sont
révisées à la baisse personne n'achète
pour vendre 60 mirage 2000 à taïwan
la france s'est pratiquement fâché avec
pékin
une situation d'autant plus difficile
pour les constructeurs aéronautiques que
l'aviation civile connaît elle aussi une
grave récession depuis la guerre du
golfe
plus de mille appareils restent cloués
au sol bien sûr il se vend toujours le
même nombre de billets mais leur prix a
baissé de plus de 10% les compagnies
civiles ont accumulé 50 milliards de
francs de déficit
la célèbre paname a totalement disparu
habituellement il se vendait 1500 avions
par an à peine 300 l'an dernier alors en
attendant on peut toujours rêver debout
à des avions à double fuselage véritable
catamaran désert à des appareils de 1000
places toujours à double fuselage mais
qui décollerait sur l'eau comme des
aéroglisseurs ou à des avions soucoupe
volante capable d'évoluer à plus de 3000
km heure domaine du rêve pas sûr cette
maquette de bloc opératoire correspond
bel et bien à l'aménagement intérieur de
ce mi-26 le plus gros hélicoptère du
monde russes bien sûr toutefois françois
mitterrand venu inaugurer le salon cet
après midi en compagnie de françois
léotard n'a eu d'yeux que pour les
productions françaises et européennes